hey whats up guys its Marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
HD tutorial and in this one in this
tutorial I plan on showing you guys a
little bit of a the features of YouTube
annotations basically and I know you
guys have used it YouTube annotations
before basically if you you know if
you've uploaded a video and I wanted to
link to your channel or on something or
link to some other video all those are
the very simple ones but I'm just going
to go through all of the YouTube
annotations here I'm going to try to go
through the easy ones quickly and then
go more in depth with the others so if I
just click on the video this happens to
me might be my video so it's not going
to do that little play pause thing but I
can go ahead and add a speech bubble a
note or a spotlight and all of these
work with linking so I'm just going to
add a spotlight so what we're going to
do in order to link this link this
annotation to something is go ahead and
hit that little paper clip link button
up there hit annotation link and we can
do a number of things here so first of
all linking to video very simple I have
to do is paste a URL to a YouTube video
there and it'll link to that video when
you click the annotation second is
playlist you can enter a link to a
YouTube playlist so if you feel like
showing someone of a playlist of other
things you've done related to this video
just go ahead and add a spotlight
annotation to a playlist the third thing
is Channel and a lot of people like to
do this add a little spotlight over
there over there watermark that leads to
their channel you can enter a channel
URL or a channel name just by simply
putting Marcus brownlee save and putting
this right on top of my mkbhd logo so
that's how a lot of people like to do
that next you guys can link to a compose
message so if you guys want to compose a
message to someone and you say you know
what if you have a question just go
ahead and send me a message well then in
that case I will go ahead and send a
compose message spotlight annotation so
just go ahead and hit that YouTube users
name or URL and that person when they
click the
when they click the spotlight annotation
it'll take them directly to the YouTube
messaging system and it'll i already
have message ready ready for them
address to that user next after compose
message is group and as you guys know
I've had my YouTube group running for a
while you have to enter actually the URL
not just the name so HTTP colon double
backslash ww youtube.com / channel /
mkbhd group and that's what you have to
do and that URL should be valid I don't
know why it's not there but yeah that's
how you do it after groups there is
collaborative annotations and that's
where you can just take this link right
here and share it with anyone and that
means anyone who clicks on that can take
can be taken and go ahead and annotate
the video themselves so I'm not going to
do that on this video but I might do a
video in the future where you know
anyone can just throw up their link and
um you know I'll put a bunch of logos on
the screen you can use spotlight
annotations on those etc and that might
be pretty fun so you go ahead and share
that URL right there for collaborative
annotations cuffed earth after that is
video response upload again it's just
linking to go ahead and upload a video
spots it's the same as clicking that
post video response button so if anyone
wants to post a video response to the
video they just click the annotation and
you'll see it takes them directly to
that same screen last but not least is
YouTube's search query and that is very
simple all you have to do is either
paste a link to the search results or
enter the search term so if you want
someone to uh you know if you're saying
well if you don't have the solution to
the problem blah blah blah all you have
to do is search you know search tiger in
the search across in the search box or
just click that annotation and it'll be
the equivalent of going up here and
typing tiger in the search box and
hitting search and that is it guys so
that is my sorry about that background
noise that is the the brief little tour
I have of the YouTube annotations I'll
go ahead and submit this as an adoptive
feature video but I yeah this is going
to be a pretty much a simple tutorial
you guys you can you know feel free to
click on any of the annotations I
demonstrated in this video if you're one
of the first to watch it they won't have
showed up but after that pretty much you
can click on any of
to see what they're like anyway that is
basically it thanks for watching this
quick tutorial and hope you liked it
catch you guys in the next video peace